how did you spend your first few years
as a screenwriter I know you said you
initially wanted to be an actor and I
know you've had you know a career as a
musician but how did you spend your
first few years as an actual
screenwriter and then how is it for you
now is it the same just more yours
behind you in terms of what you don't
like what you do like oh it's much
different it's so um when I first wrote
screenplays you know you're right you're
writing it for the the fun of the medium
or you want to write movies or be in the
film business or you have a great story
to tell whatever your reasons are
combination of all those things but when
you what happened for me is we had an
agent as I said from this little script
and once you have an agent especially
you're at a big agency like WME you have
access and when you have access it
charges you to make you know now you can
really write because you know you can
get the screenplay to people it's you
know it's a different thing
and so I wrote a couple bigger movies
bigger in action movies I guess we'll
call them and these movies went into the
big studios and they got and then they
went through the engine the factory and
the writer can get really destroyed in
that Factory and I got destroyed in that
factory doesn't happen all the time but
I wrote a couple popcorn movies and they
got rewritten head to toe one of them
didn't get made one did but it was an
excruciating experience and it really
quite frankly made me not want to write
anymore that's really when I got into
directing because my feeling was I don't
know if I'm a good director but I really
don't know if I'm a good writer was the
thing so maybe if I I mean if I shoot my
words myself like a short film
I'll know if I really belong here or not
you know and I did this short film
called brink we shouldn't have a lot of
dialogue in it and people it was very
short film a kind of a sci-fi romance
real quiet film beautiful music by my
composer darin morsy actually made the
film based on his music and it was for
freshing because as i said it didn't
have a lot of dialogue so I really
didn't have a script I didn't write a
script for this film and it was fun to
just direct something not write it
because I was so I really didn't think I
was a good writer
at that point and it's nice to just work
with friends I had a camera we shot this
short film and I mean we just started
doing short films and myself and my
producing partner Damon Russell and then
I got into directing and that was that
kind of rounded me back to liking to
write again because I realized that I
can I can have confidence in some of
what I do I don't have confidence and
most of what I do but I can have
confidence in writing again
once I started directing
you